buona sera io sono nicola giardini e
questa sera vi parlerò del stampa 3d
applicata al dis e dispositivi medici su
misura
la storia che sto per raccontarvi parla
innanzitutto di tre amici alessandro
sorry geometra abilitato e responsabile
di una pmi locale federico papi
laureando in ingegneria edile
modellatore tridimensionale e appunto io
che sono laureata in ingegneria edile e
un perito meccanico
parlo di tre amici perché la nostra
storia comincia con una convivenza che è
durata un anno un anno all'inizio del
nostro corso di studio abbiamo vissuto
insieme una casa a firenze alessandro
ponente rotto di studi per dedicarsi al
lavoro mentre io e federico abbiamo
continuato per circa sette anni a vivere
sotto lo stesso tetto
la nostra idea nasce parte muove i primi
passi grazie a concorso di terre di
siena creative organizzato dalla
provincia di siena nella sua seconda
edizione del 2013
siamo stati premiati i secondi
classificati a gennaio 2014 e il sito
ottenuto ci ha permesso di partire con
la startup la genesi dell'idea nasce da
un'esigenza specifica come potete vedere
le mie spalle
sono appassionato di sport
motociclistici che pratico
purtroppo motociclette e ortopedia vanno
spesso a braccetto
infatti in quella che si può vedere in
foto è una radiografia di una mia mano a
seguito di un incidente occorso durante
l'allenamento dopo dopo l'intervento mi
è stato prescritto un tutore standard
che il premier ha causato molti problemi
non ultimo il fatto che fosse
sicuramente non traspirabile non era
lavabile e non stata paola una famiglia
della mia mano che aveva un ferro al suo
interno in quel momento
analizzando poi questa tipologia di
tutori ci siamo resi conto che ci sono
criticità anche per quanto riguarda e
chi li vende chi le produce chi li vende
c'è sicuramente il rischio di invenduto
c'è sicuramente un rischio di
insoddisfazione del paziente e cioè
sicuramente uno scarso margine la
risposta che abbiamo immaginato prevede
sostanzialmente l'adozione di
dispositivi medici stampati su misura
sono traspirabili sono leggeri sono
anatomici garantiscono sicuramente un
maggior valore aggiunto sul prodotto e
quindi una soddisfazione del
dei clienti o del paziente il processo
produttivo che porta alla realizzazione
di questi oggetti è sicuramente
economico con una spesa contenuta per
quanto riguarda le tecnologie e costa di
tre fasi una scansione tridimensionale
dell'arte anna falcone coda diciamo
immobilizzare o trattare una
modellazione tridimensionale ed una
stampa 3d già la stampa 3d
ne sentiamo parlare spesso oggi molto
spesso sui media e passa anche tutto
stone in stream come cosa
le tecnologie sono di tre grandi
famiglie asl o sls ed fdm le prime due
condividono il fatto di utilizzare un
laser che scioglie il materiale che poi
sia sotto forma di polvere o resina
liquida mentre la fdm scioglie e un
filamento liquido lo deposita strato su
strato proprio grazie a questa
tecnologia sia avuto con un brevetto di
strapaese depositato nel 92 è scaduto
intorno al 2005 una diffusione massiva
di quelli che sono le stampanti grazie
al progetto re troppo il primo progetto
open source da questo progetto di
scendono quasi tutte le stampanti che
oggi conosciamo a basso costo non ultima
quella abbiamo acquistato noi da una
locale e start up fiorentina quando
abbiamo questa tra stampante ci
immaginavamo di ottenere oggetti finiti
così come l'avevamo modellati purtroppo
i primi risultati non sono stati così
confortanti e questo ci ha fatto
riflettere ci ha fatto ragionare sul
fatto di dover realizzare un ciclo
produttivo che fosse semplice alla
portata di tecnici del settore che non
necessariamente fossero riso e
conoscenze informatiche
abbiamo vende realizzato degli ausili
per la scansione queste sono stati
modellati progettati e stampati da noi
in maniera da semplificare il processo
qui possiamo vedere la mano che è stata
acquisita ed in seguito ci siamo
concentrati sulla seconda fase quella
che ancora oggi ha comunque un problema
è la modellazione di questi oggetti e
questa modellazione della si è resa
facile e soprattutto realizzabile da
tecnici del settore che sanno dove
devono essere utilizzati come devono
essere utilizzati questi dispositivi
sanno quali sono i punti di taglio che
definiscono la geometria dell'oggetto
che devono essere realizzati e sanno
quali sono i movimenti che devono essere
bloccati in base alla patologia in
questo punto
a questo punto del video stiamo vedendo
come questo script d'amore a questo
programma che abbiamo realizzato che
oggi presentiamo ha fra l'altro
un'anteprima consenta attraverso
semplicemente gesti di drag and drop di
definire la geometria del tutore che poi
verrà realizzato immaginiamo che questo
sia fattibile da un tecnico del settore
che non sia necessariamente abile con lo
strumento informatico qui stiamo vedendo
come stanno venendo definiti i piani di
taglio laterali che serviranno a
stabilire quanto il dispositivo deve
essere avvolgente o meno su quella che è
la mano all arto o quale che sia insomma
l'oggetto su cui verrà realizzato e
dispositivo medico su misura al termine
di questa fase dati vengono inviati ad
una centrale di elaborazione sulla quale
gira un programma di modellazione che
attraverso uno script che abbiamo
realizzato noi definisce la geometria
del tutore che appunto ora viene
esportato possiamo vedere a questo punto
viene proposto a chi dovrà venire
proposta che ha realizzato il
dispositivo
il modello finito pronto per essere
stampato in questo modo si può e chi è
chi lo ha realizzato per rendersi conto
se ciò che è stato modellato risponde
alle necessità che lui prevede di avere
sul paziente specifico quindi al termine
lo valida e diciamo vari dal trattamento
terapeutico ultima fase la stampa delle
di in questo caso è realizzata con la
nostra stampante
ma ci sono altre domande che poi sono
subito seguite come quale dinamica
utilizzeremo per far diffondere questi
questi oggetti
abbiamo immaginato sostanzialmente due
scenari un primo scenario in cui la
sanitaria un tecnico ortopedico
acquistano tutto il pacchetto le tre
fasi quindi scanner software di
modellazione e stampanti e una seconda
fase una seconda possibilità diciamo in
cui il tecnico ed che acquista solamente
due parti della diciamo del terzetto e
demanda ad un servizio iii la stampa
dell'oggetto servizi che tra l'altro
stanno sorgendo come piccoli funghi
all'interno di varie province e città
italiane i futuri sviluppi che
immaginiamo per questa tecnologia
riguardano tre ambiti biometria pro
technology a
vorrebbe il device di cui tra l'altro
che parleranno breve per quanto riguarda
la biometria abbiamo già osservato come
nella realizzazione dispositivi medici
su misura spesso vengono prese misure ma
che ci sia una forte alleato rifà della
misura la stessa misura presa da due
persone diverse
molto probabilmente sarà diversa e
quindi necessario un tipo di misura
oggettiva
abbiamo realizzato un prototipo che fa
questo ha costruite a basso costo che
fra l'altro abbiamo utilizzato per
validare la precisione e renderci conto
ma della precisione degli strumenti
stiamo utilizzando per quanto riguarda
la protesi elogi abbiamo analizzato il
mercato abbiamo osservato come ci siano
due tipologie di produzione di protesi
elogi a una molto artigianale ed una
multa tecnologica immaginiamo che la
stampa 3d possa frapporsi fra queste due
innalzando il livello di contenuto
tecnologico della prima da abbassando i
costi della seconda per quanto riguarda
invece il cast onorevole device abbiamo
immaginato come possono essere
implementati secondo due scopi un primo
scopo di tipo terapeutico che possa
aiutare a seguire l'evolversi della
patologia del paziente o anche inserire
diversi diversi trattamenti mentre per
quanto riguarda la seconda ipotesi è
l'idea di vendere questi tutori non solo
su tory ma anche dispositivi di
interazione con gli strumenti
tecnologici che ci circondano
per quanto riguarda i vantaggi per la
comunità invece abbiamo osservato nome
sicuramente l'adozione di questa
tecnologia potrebbe portare ad avere una
alzamento della soglia della soglia
tecnologica dei dispositivi e
contestualmente con la sua diffusione
un abbassamento del costo per quindi
renderli più accessibili
il secondo vantaggio per la comunità che
riportiamo molto importante è andare
contro quella che è la tendenza alla
delocalizzazione delle imprese che
sempre rivolta oggi sempre più guardano
nuovi orizzonti e nuovi mercati per
produrre i propri prodotti
l'adozione e lo sfruttamento di questo
genere in tecnologia consentirebbe un
frazionamento della produzione in tanti
piccoli centri e quindi molto
probabilmente un ritorno all'artigianato
di qualità che potrebbe essere un nuovo
e che è stato in passato e potrebbe
essere oggi un nuovo impulso per quella
che è la nostra economia e per questo ed
altri motivi ci immaginiamo e speriamo
che questa tecnologia prenda casa
grazie